I'm sorry those girls were so mean they
didn't just call me a boy they wouldn't
sit with me at lunch no one talked to me
at recess Oh baby somebody crossed up
Missy Cooper my notebook and wrote mr.
Cooper well if that's what they're like
maybe you don't want them as friends I
don't think I want to play baseball
anymore if it's what you want is your
decision
[Music]
hello I heard your daughter's playing
baseball hey Brenda what were you
thinking
excuse me my Billy's on that team
baseball's for boys says who says
everyone it's not ladylike
Thanks the pony for your father Oh okay
where was that you were telling me what
was ladylike and then yelled at your son
like a duck Foreman listen I'm just
doing you a favor
the other moms on the team are starting
to talk well maybe the other moms need
to mind their own business
come on Mary is it one weird kid and
your family enough you're going for a
record
you're playing baseball but you said it
was my decision it is and you're flying
[Music]
you praying I'm asking the Lord to watch
over my little girl while you're in it
ask him for a win I got money on this
you bent on a kids baseball game
I got three-to-one odds thanks to dr.
Sturgis I had all the intellectual
ammunition I needed to bring my opponent
to his knees I accused him of conflating
two different interpretations of quantum
theory woefully misrepresenting Paul
Dirac and when I called him a dung
beetle in Latin I was so riled up I
almost started producing testosterone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it happens she's okay
[Music]
Hey Boulder we talked about this
[Music]
do a job
[Music]
[Music]
the long-awaited for bottle form I still
believe my theory has merit I will
concede the point for some validity
[Music]
that day both my sister and I emerged
victorious from savage battles hers
fought with fists mine with words
[Applause]
although we were both pretty sore the
next day ejected from your very first
game I'm proud of you slugger thanks dad
here he Queens on me to be clear we are
not rewarding violence but I am glad you
didn't let those girls from school bully
you and equipment I shrugged their faces
in the dirt that's my girl
done let's get the extra sprinkles
tonight